[Musique]
rien de bon
soldat laforêt derrière vous et
l'indéterminé les plus dangereux de ce
siècle
c'est internet mission est très simple
et une blague sur internet
beaucoup ont essayé très peu en sont
revenus vivants religions ethnies
homosexualité féminisme politique sujets
sont très sensibles au mieux passé
aventurer
mais si le black est subtil et bien fait
sergent le faire le malin soldats
compris tout à blaye
les femmes mais tutorat se préparer dans
la salle de bain parce que
[Musique]
on vient de perdre l'un de nos hommes
pour une blague misogyne j'ai explosif
snipers isolés mines antipersonnel
barbelés grenade et parfois même en bus
call fait attention à tout ce que vous
dites ici sergent on peut même pas faire
une simple blague sur les nains ont dit
pana ont des personnes de petite taille
je viens de te prendre une balle de
tweetos du 33 mt en plus bref ne
plaisantait pas avec ces sujets sur
internet ou finirait comme lui mais
sergent pourtant certains y arrivent
clientèle des choses aussi sensible ça
s'est déjà vu non ouais mais ce ne sont
pas les soldats soldats ce sont des
légendes
et c'est moi
[Musique]
ça donne pas envie internet en toute
cette méchanceté gratuite
ouais mais dire un truc sur internet ou
même à faire une simple blague c'est
notre mission c'est curieux anciennement
les appeler l'armée rouge les bourses
rouges et la légende raconte que
certains d'entre eux seraient même les
enfants-soldats n'arrive vraiment
horrible
[Musique]
puis c'est toto il est enfermé aux
toilettes hélas sa frappe à la porte
s'est il fait une blague de merde y'a
aucune mine qui explose on lui tape pas
dessus [ __ ] c'est normal il à la
médaille de la hype
sauf que là avec ne dure qu'un temps
désormais les gens ont déjà oublié il
est fini à tout jamais excusez moi eh
les mecs je te rejoins votre armée à lui
tout seul compass s'est pris un obus à
bad buzz pour des propos sexistes
ils pourraient tous sont contaminés pas
de rt pathak pas de mention surtout pas
toi je sais que tu aimes ça c'est bon
les gars là j'arrête tout c'est pour ça
m'a saoulé là je vais dans le nord c'est
beaucoup plus safe ya pas de mine pas de
barbelés et huelva nom de dieu elle va
dans la zone des podcasts la raclette
faire les courses tout ça c'est une zone
safe mais au bout d'un moment si fait un
peu chier c'est bien de la merde
ouais bon des fois je suis un peu
l'école dans ma carrière on va contient
let's go c'est le froid qui nous attend
madoff paca
ici on évoque tueur du champ de bataille
des rageux prions tomber dessus à chaque
instant sa gaffe à toi tu es gimont moto
mais ça je sais temps calme j'aime pas
trop ça
bon si c'est quand même temps bien on
n'a rien d'accord
oh mon dieu tu viens de faire une blague
faith s'est plaint des tiges et les
explosifs
on va tous mourir n'est pas bonne à tout
jamais attention un bombardement des
commentaires
regardez ce champ a sévi dans des caves
à l'aide
moi j'aime beaucoup sur les réseaux
sociaux ou rire un peu mais maintenant
je suis passé ici
mais ces gens il faut l'aider non ça
date
c'est une des parcelles derrière dans un
tel climat de haine et d'animosité est
d'ailleurs gratuite c'est trop pour moi
pose des armes maintenant à vous de
cette bière quant à ses chances c'est
pas moins de se dégonfler ok oui et si
but de là bas il a juste envie de filles
vous comprenez rires il s'en fout les
attaques sociales bah moi c'est
tellement vos ennemis que vous pensez de
votre émission fait une blague sur
internet si un peuple à manquer vous
imaginez toujours penser comme vous qui
habitez plus d'humour si ça vous voulez
je pense pas donc ce qu'on va faire on
va les voir ces civils on veut le mettre
sur un gros cave et on va livrer mes
plaques de même oui c'était ben oui ça
fait perdre alors j'ai pu le karité
essais en mer tous section animal côté
à
l'histoire d'un belge d'un juif et du
peuple est bon mais c'est tout ce qui
sort en femme parce qu'il a changé texte
hu à la crème des pourquoi moi c'est pas
chaud il a osé alors la battle network
général une fois que la terre explosé
c'est là que bob l'eponge dire c'était
pas une once de ma femme
par contre la chute n'était pas ouf
ouais c'était pas où mais un gars
non c'est pas taillé deuxième merci et
bravo à vous soldats en plus d'après un
calcul
ici on est dans la zone des allégories
par exemple allégorie de comparer
internet un terrain miné
en gros ici c'est ultra sai on n'a plus
rien à craindre
vous êtes sûr là parce que ça fait bip
bip sous nos pieds monsieur va falloir
être fort
elle vient de gagner une bataille mais
on est bien loin d'avoir gagné la guerre
soldats pourtant engagée dans ma chaîne
youtube clic sans ma tête et abonne toi
nous avons besoin de gens comme vous
pour un jeu vif qui ont soif d'aventurés
et qui ont la peau douce se lave avec un
savon hypoallergénique
c'est la base